[Music]
reinvention to me means thinking a step
ahead thinking it a bit further pushing
the envelope and also solving a problem
I think it's important sometimes to
question what we do in order to move
forward and actually to better things
[Music]
ala Perez I think we're real perching
the fashion industry by bringing vegan
fashion to the forefront my early career
was in luxury and basically I knew too
well how many projects were made so me
and my business partner we made it our
mission to create products that are just
better for the environment and we
actually started the business as a
direct-to-consumer but honestly it was
much harder than we thought when we
started so we were not eating the
numbers and decided to open a pop-up and
that's where we start selling our faux
fur and they kept selling out I do
believe that if online we were doing
well we would have maybe never open that
pop-up and by not opening this pop-up we
would have never understood that they
were true need in the market for faux
fur another very interesting thing and
it's all about timing I believe when
you're an entrepreneur is that the
fashion director from Bloomingdale's
reach out to us because she saw a pop up
in our footer and that was also from
your sign that we were really on
something and I think that's a big
takeaway from this is to really
understand the power of adaptability to
be able to bounce back if you are in a
struggle if it's not really the way you
think you would go I think it's okay and
again it's about reinvention and
thinking a step further and you okay to
say this is not working and to make a
move
I think that's what entrepreneurship is
about is really fighting hurdles and
difficulties in order to grow
[Music]
you